on this session today i want to talk to
you a little bit about visual studio
code vs code
how we can be productive
on python
using vs code generically then
specifically for data science okay how
we can use it for data science in a
productive way there's a bunch of new
announcements that we've done in the
last couple of months and the last one
two days ago and i'm going to walk you
through this
through demos and last but not least uh
walk you a little bit into
the azure machine learning
services
and mlaps
let's start first with python by the
numbers and and you might have seen this
before the adoption of python is is
brutal okay
it's not just in college it's not just
for
enthusiasts it's not just for young kids
it's probably one of the first languages
that's that that's super universal and
goes everywhere and these numbers that
you see here i'm pretty sure they're
gonna grow another two percent year on
year now let's dig in a little bit into
vs code
now how many of you know vs code or use
show hands quite a few of you cool thank
you
you've seen vs code it has obviously
built in language support intellisense
you can type in and you'll get a little
bit of an advice on on on how that um or
linting on how that those functions work
or what else can you type um debugging
obviously integration with git or other
code repositories for me the best thing
is obviously it's free it's class in its
cross-platform meaning today i can be on
this device
next day or next hour i can be on that
device and this is something i do very
frequently same experience
works the same
really really quick
obviously being fast and lightweight is
super important for me also i used to
use visual studio and visual studio is
still an awesome ide for very specific
workloads very high-end professional
developer for me for a lot of the work
that i do
the fact that i can just launch this vs
code like that whatever i am and get it
done is super important for me
now
also very important is the python
extension which is where vs code comes
into really
full
full circle with python that extension
right now the microsoft one is the most
used uh um pythonic extension is updated
every month there's a vlog um a blog
that follows and every month gives the
updates and and the links are at the end
of the slide and you can follow along
what we've seen now i'll show a little
bit of where we are today with this but
if i look a year ago i would use vs code
with python in particular for like if i
was doing something on flask no problem
for sure for that the science i would
still be leaning on either doing
anything or everything on a notebook or
doing some things on spider or other ids
today where we are today i'm pretty
comfortable on doing everything on vs
code already and it keeps growing and
growing every month
another interesting thing that i will
demo is remote development okay so
and one of the examples i'm going to
show i'm not going to show you wsl wsl
is the wind the window subsystem for
linux it's basically a linux kernel that
you might have heard runs inside windows
10 machines so basically if you have
windows 10 you install an ubuntu or any
other distribution that's supported and
you basically just open the shell and
you have a best shell on that micro
container running
on windows
because today i'm not using using a
windows machine i will use something
else which is i will use remote
development on a container on a docker
container on this machine here
and basically imagine the following
scenario you have a lot of environments
or you have a special configuration that
needs to run on a specific version of
linux spin up a container the code
automatically gets deployed the
environment that you want automatically
gets deployed to that container and you
run the code from vs code on your
machine remotely on that container
i think this is better shown than talked
about so i'm going to
demo
all of this to you so i have a basic
plot from the matplotlib
you can just
get it running
locally and you you you get what you
would expect to see a sign function uh
no big thing there um if you you can
obviously start seeing the the linting
and the help obviously going when you
over
over the functions
um other things you can do you can run
the current file on an interactive
window that's one of the first thing
that's interesting so now you actually
have interactive python running in i can
close this window let me open up a
little bit more space you actually have
interactive python running inside the s
code in reality what's doing it's as you
can see it's spinning up jupyter
notebook okay in your local machine
and you basically have
this code that i was running
right here same thing same thing and
this is a normal interactive window so
if i do import
numpy
snp
whoops sn b
np dot bye
you'll see it's a normal interactive uh
normal interactive mode i can run pieces
of this code also
what you expected to see um
sorry give me a second
run selection for instance in the python
terminal so i can still run it on the
terminal down here i can run it directly
on the interactive window there's a lot
of work i can do in between this either
the interactive console or the common
line so and this is this is really what
i'm starting to see that that type of
interaction that i used to have or need
a notebook or need another ide now it
comes full circle inside
inside vs code which makes me much more
productive if i open up obviously i have
access to the plots i can all the plots
that i'm using i can zoom in zoom out a
very
very actually very productive way of
working directly from the uh from the
uh from the ide another interesting
thing that we have here is obviously the
variables um
so you have all the variables that i'm
using on this
interactive console
so you can explore the variables you can
actually look at the data
and for instance you can filter it let
me see i want to filter only the zero
point ones
whoops 0.1 there you go those are the
items so it's it gives you a little bit
of extra productivity
features that you can do directly from
uh from the the the interactive window
now
what i like about this is if you see
something that you're missing
because the product group that's
developing this um the python
tools for uh for vs code they are so
open you can just
go get get engaged with them on either
through the blog or on github and just
request a new feature okay so again
every month new features today very
comfortable with what i see i'm fully
productive straight on vs code but we
can keep adding and you can keep
requesting more things to come
into play let now let's go into remote
as i um as i've shown you before we were
running all of this locally right so
um
[Music]
i'm on my
i'm locally on this machine
okay i'm gonna now connect to a
container okay
inside this machine so a docker
container with a um
basically a linux version
it's going to ask me to pick um uh
pick an interpreter just give me a
second to
it will get there i don't need this
right now
select the right i'm gonna go here
it's full on okay i'm gonna run it
hold on sorry
yes
and you saw basically it created this
you don't because it's on a container
you don't get to see the obviously the
the matplotlib output but it created
this the same image okay and if you
don't believe me
you can see that we are not on my mac
okay
we're on the that linux container that i
was creating before
i can go back and say oh i want to go
back to my machine reopen locally
and if i run it again you'll see i'm
running on
hold on sorry i need to pick paint the
right interpreter give me a second
and you can do and here's the
interesting thing right now you can do
it from here or you can just go again
on the window sorry on the window up
there and just pick the
pic select the interpreter the python
interpreter from here okay
i'm gonna use this one i'm gonna run it
again
come on
there you go
as you can see and i'm on on this
machine okay so these are basics that
show you the beginning of where we are
in terms of using um productively vs
code for a lot of scenarios for which in
the past i used to need other
other tools to complement vs code
now let's look a little bit into data
science inside vs code we saw uh um
obviously we saw a little bit about
notebooks and that's fine um
but when you look at machine learning on
azure um the bigger picture that we have
and i'm sorry if the
kind of the the fonts might be a little
bit small uh on the screen we look at it
from five layers basically um the first
one is we can look at working with
pre-trained models
i'm sorry oh if we can dim the
spotlights thank you um
would it be possible thank you very much
thank you apologies for that
uh so on the top layer we're looking at
pre-trained models okay so what i call
ai as a service so if you want to look
into a computer vision you have a
computer vision problem you have a
speech
natural language
problem
you need cognitive search you can just
call an api and pass it to date and get
get a response either with them in the
case of computer vision
this object is class a b c d so a
typical classification problem i see
object x in this picture
as a a an image detection problem you
can do all of that
by calling apis that's kind of the
pretend model approach the second layer
is actually building when you need to
build
when you need to build
models by yourself you can use code as
we saw before you can use notebooks
command line or other ides then comes
the frameworks that you want to build on
and obviously will support any framework
that you decide to build on my preferred
one today is keras with a
tensorflow backend but i'm seeing for
instance pi torch being phenomenally
used um and now the fast ai library on
top of pi torch on top of pi torch being
delivering
phenomenal results when it comes to ease
of use and uh and performance okay and
obviously then we go into the kind of
the model management layers okay where
we'll talk about azure machine learning
and at the bottom obviously we'll have
basically the hardware infrastructure in
which we train and run these models
which can be cpus
gpus fpgas
deployed on premises on the cloud
on your device on your phone or on your
iot gateway
now we're going to focus a little bit
first on vs code and notebooks so the
first news i want to share um
is that
obviously we can now work very closely
with notebooks inside vs code and the
one the thing that was announced two
days ago is actually we used to have to
import the notebook now we can actually
open the notebook natively um inside vs
code okay and we can do things like
debugging of cells we can indirectly add
cells either in a python file or in the
notebook itself so there's a we've shown
i've shown you already a couple of these
things here but it's really really
interesting to see so i'm going to jump
straight into the demo
okay the first thing i want to show you
is talk to you about
this exact
problem that i have it's a custom vision
problem so i wanna pass a picture of
um of a picture of a plane and i want it
to tell me which hairline is on that
picture okay simple
typical uh image classification problem
okay so this is what i did in the
beginning on my laptop i built a model
on tensorflow and this is just the code
the inference code basically to just go
and show what's happening on the
uh on that picture so if you look at and
this is the image okay
um this is just calling the inference
model okay
and then
outputting the the result okay
which is
and this model is super sure with
99.99 accuracy that's a a plane from
singapore airlines okay so i'm gonna
move back into
into um
into vs code and i'm gonna and you see i
have here the python notebook i'm going
to open it
and what you'll see
after a little bit is that actually i
have a similar
jupiter interface inside vs code now you
might like jupiter on a white background
and i know i like visual studio with a
black black round so this might look a
little bit different but i promise if
you turn the the theme of yes code into
a white theme you'll this looks much
much closer to a
normal normal jupiter notebook so i
could run this straight down and we'll
do exactly the same thing okay so that
that's the
uh the first thing i can do and i and i
can call any of this line you see here i
can rearrange them i can insert new
lines i can still use
the variables as before
as i showed before now the other thing
that we can use is actually to import
this into a python file so actually i
have the jupyter notebook i want to
import it into
to a python script
okay
and here you have the same code let me
just close the window to maximize a
little bit here you have the same code
fully on
already
as a python file okay and what you'll
see here is that one when i put this tag
and i'm going to put it here
the same thing
when i put these tags inside which
obviously you can see they are comments
it's just vs code is interpreting those
python comments as something else when i
put those tags here i can start treating
that python file
as a discrete
almost like a notebook
experience so it's halfway between a
pure python experience and a notebook i
can have like something in the middle
that in the ide behaves like a notebook
but if i take it out of the ide it's a
normal python file okay so that's
something that's actually super cool and
i'm really um excited about using more
recently
trying to make sure i don't forget to
demo anything to you guys today
what i can do i actually i can
go back
to the basic plot
and what i can do here don't save
if i go here i can do the same thing
which is i will put this here
and i can debug the cell
so it's going to run
and it's going to show me a debug window
and there you'll see in that
i didn't have to set the breakpoint i
could do almost like a fake break point
you'll have the
the preds um
it's actually it's doesn't matter it was
for another another uh python file but
you'll have here the local variables
okay
and you have access to the call stack
and everything that's going on okay even
from the debugging experience the
ability to do this it's really really
cool
okay
let me go back
now when we look at the frameworks and
i'm gonna i know we're running we
started a little bit late apologies for
that so i'll try to accelera accelerate
a little bit when you look at the the
frameworks that we support we support
obviously the typical data science and
machine learning frameworks that
everybody is working on or most people
are working on obviously but we also did
an intentional effort with with facebook
and now with several other companies on
building an interchangeable format
called onyx which you can see on the on
the right
i it's it's picking up adoption
obviously it's not mainstream today but
it's picking up adoption as a really
good language lingua franca between the
different machine learning models okay
and it allows us for instance in my case
to deploy a model that i put on onyx
that i can download from the web
deployed immediately on very different
types of devices and that form factor is
important because today we think of like
this model it carries with a tensorflow
black end
backend if i want to deploy it on
my phone versus this machine versus an
iot gateway it's going to be completely
different
once the full promise of 1x is there i
have one model converted into onyx that
can be deployed on any platform okay
regardless of being an edge platform a
full-on inference
cluster in the cloud or my own mobile
device so that's something we're working
on with facebook and a lot of other
hardware vendors and that we hope to see
uh come forward um as an open open
source and an open consortium
for this to fix kind of the
proliferation of model models and model
management frameworks
now
i'm going to talk a little bit about
azure machine learning services okay
and
kind of the problem that we've seen so
far so so that that that example i
showed before of that inference of the
airline i built it on my laptop i
trained it on actually on that one which
is a surface pro with the geforce um
discrete graphics card um i deployed
locally the first couple of times takes
15 minutes to to to build a model makes
a lot of noise because all the fans
start working um and i can only get an
accuracy of 90
okay because the small the file size is
small
i have to make a lot of compromises to
run on a machine like that what if i had
a platform super easy to just deploy
that model take care of the training of
the data versioning of the model
versioning of the deployment to a web
service all of that end to end without
me having to write all the code by
myself okay and that's what i'm going to
show you with azure machine learning
service okay again it's basically a
platform for helping you manage your
data science life cycle in a more
productive way more productive and also
more collaborative meaning obviously i'm
submitting the code to github that code
can be seen by anyone else but also if
anyone else wants to run an experiment
based on my data or based on my
experiment pipeline they can do it all
the same essentially from the same uh
repository and from the same platform
so
beyond uh beyond a little bit of um
beyond that the azure machine learning
services also gives us several different
interfaces for several different types
of users today i'm going to focus on
notebooks again and on the sdk with vs
code but depending on your level of
proficiency with code and with data
science you could either use automated
machine learning
or you could use
a visual interface okay and if you kind
of look at the split depending on
whether you're a full-on data scientist
or you are a
full-on developer or both or neither you
will have some of the right tools
for doing the right job okay and that
full support
is where we want to be at okay
today as i said i'm going to focus on
the top-end python sdk and
notebooks so on the notebook vms so
immediately as part of the back-end from
the azure machine learning services you
have access to notebook vms which you
can provision decide which size you want
the machine to be whether it wants to be
a gpu enable or not
or not a machine whether you want it to
be always running or you want to have a
pool of up to five vms that start only
on demand whenever someone requests one
of them you can obviously tune all
all of that the good thing is that
whenever someone starts a notebook on
one of those vms immediately everything
is configured they don't have to go and
mess about getting the right conda
environment or the right packages
installed it should be covering the vast
majority of what's needed today okay and
as it gets updated because you can pull
uh new versions obviously you'll get the
latest versions of tensorflow right now
with 2.0 you'll get the latest versions
of everything um that that's coming up
same applies for the sdk
better shown than
than than told so i'm gonna go into the
demo again before i go into the demo
obviously i'm gonna show a lot of this
both on the ui on the web and on vs code
whatever you see on the ui which is
where i'm going to start you can also
access nvs code through the azure
machine learning extension for vs code
so the first extension i showed was
python the second one i will show a
little bit is the the the same extension
for azure machine learning
now the scenario i'm going to walk you
through is
what's in there okay step one we kind of
do we i didn't show you how i trained
that model but i showed you the
inference piece on my local machine
if you remember
you can see it's running on my machine
okay
step two that we're gonna go is we're
gonna go
into azure machine learning studio i'm
going to show it then i'm going to go
into another notebook and i'm going to
do the model training or show you how to
do the training and the and the
monitoring of the training process and
saving that resulting model in a central
repository that's obviously version and
can be shared by different people step
number three i'm going to take that
model and i'm going to deploy it as a
web service also using jupyter notebooks
last step i'll just run inference on
that model which is what we did on the
first step but by calling the web
service that i deployed through azure
machine learning services okay you can
see um the architecture on on the right
or a macro architecture of what i'm
trying to achieve okay
cool let's go into ml.azure.com
apologies if there is any glitches the
good thing of being on preview on the
preview uh branch is that i uh sometimes
they deploy things overnight like they
did this night so
i hope i find all the buttons in the
right place
and no unexpected glitches so what
you'll see here i talked about automated
machine learning visual interfaces we're
going to focus primarily on notebooks
today okay
um
obviously as part of a productive data
science life cycle management platform
you have your data sets they are
versioned the idea of versioning them is
basically being able to build a model
based on different versions of the data
but at the same time
once the model gets deployed and the
static data drift in understanding
whether we need to flow back and retrain
the model based on the model performance
in production as it as time goes by
obviously the experiments that i'm
running at a specific point in time i
might be running several experiments i
might have many models on the same
experiment
the models themselves that i built as
part of those experiments and the
endpoints which is basically just the
web service endpoints that i can build
based on those models to
[Music]
infer for inference basically okay
on the management side so this is kind
of the the the machine learning
experience on the management side you'll
have the ability obviously to manage
your clusters those are the compute
clusters i have um
in this part
in this workspace by the way the macro
container for this is called the
workspace it's an azure machine learning
workspace
you can see i have the cpu cluster has
one node running i can come in and say
you know what
i actually don't need
anything running right now because i'm
not training um if i do need training
i'm okay with waiting you for for you to
spin up the machine okay so now you'll
see it's gonna start decommissioning
uh resizing now it's resizing from one
to zero what this means is that before
if i wanted to run the run um an
experiment targeting that specific
cluster if i only run one it starts
immediately if i run two it waited for
the machine to build right now because
i'm resizing whatever i target that
cluster we'll need to wait for a couple
of a couple of seconds to spin up one
machine
okay let's go into the notebooks the
first thing we're going to do is we're
going to look into deploying a model
okay and because i believe and you'll
see here a very usual uh
notebook experience because i believe
most folks are more
uh
are more um
give me a second to reconnect are more
uh
used to the normal jupiter notebook so
what i'll do i'll just go behind the
scenes
the same the same cluster that i'm
running with the same azure
compute
sorry the same
notebook vms that's running okay i'm
just going behind the scenes and you can
see there's no magic i'm abstracting
this from you but if you want to see the
the notebook itself you can see the
notebook itself okay uh um which will be
the notebook platform i'm gonna go and
look at the first way to train on a
remote cluster remember first i was just
training locally i didn't show you that
code but it was locally now i'm going to
show you
how to do the training remotely now
basically i'm loading that workspace
that i show you i shown you before on
the ui i'm loading it
um it's this one here i'm telling which
experiment i want to run this on this
particular training i'm i'm and then i'm
doing something interesting which is i'm
putting the training
the training script i'm writing locally
on the file why because when i deploy
this on the cluster this is going to run
and it's going to write this code
locally as the training.pi which is
the file i want it to run to run um it's
basically you can see it here it's
just um
it's a transfer learning model it uses
exception okay so i'm not building this
from scratch i'm using exception
um and obviously it takes 15 minutes i'm
not going to do this right now one of
the good things is that i can train this
because it's on the gpu cluster on much
bigger image sizes so on my local
machine i was trying on 71 by 71 which
is the minimum for exception here i can
do 200. so obviously the accuracy jumped
once i train the model here and you can
see um here i'm building the environment
for the training job so i'm telling them
i'm telling the the cluster management
tool here's the the condo environment i
need here's the
packages that are in the the python
packages that i need and so on okay
i'm telling it which target to do in
this case i told it to run on a data
science vm um on azure um i'm giving it
a little bit like the training file a
little bit more information
and then it starts running okay and then
i can monitor on the portal while it's
running what i can monitor here because
i know the name of the run i can do this
which is just run it
here and you can see the logs it already
run and if i look at the log for this
specif specific run that i run i did
last night
um you can see that it achieved an
accuracy of 0.99.41
that kind of took
took 15 minutes roughly 50 minutes to
run the full um the full process okay
so now it's
i train the model i have a model i
actually saved it locally as part of my
training
file
you will see
here that i saved it locally okay
i saved it locally in the output folder
so what i will do
i will just register the model okay i'll
take that model and i'll register it on
our model registry so it's here and you
can see it created a new version for
that meaning it's obvious again data was
version data sensor version models our
version a b test comparison of data
models everything along the way you see
the productivity that you can achieve
with this right
now i want to deploy this i have a model
it's in my central repository
now i want to deploy that as a web
service okay
so i will again connect to the sdk i
will open up the workspace
i will look in
exactly all the models that are in there
i pick the model i want to deploy which
is the one i served before in train
before i'll create the docker image for
scoring for the inference piece um so
basically this is just the inference
code it's very similar to the one i did
on the first notebook if you can see uh
same thing i pass it an image of an
airline and it tells me uh which
hairline is in the picture okay
again i i pass it the dependencies that
i need for that specific environment to
run okay i'm going to tell it exactly
what do i need like
probably in this case it's not yeah very
basic
packages
it then creates the
image the container image
and it deploys it
exactly sorry
this step is to deploy the image in a
registry okay uh in azure container
registry if you can if you go back here
it's deploying here
and then taking that register and
deploying the image as a
an aci image okay meaning that you can
get it deployed without the need for any
orchestrator if you want to deploy to
kubernetes for instance perfect you can
do it okay
and the last step is to actually expose
it as a web service okay and what you
have here it will give you an a web
service endpoint
that if you go here you can explore
obviously it's here
the end point okay i'm gonna go very
quickly back to
vs code because i know we're running out
of time and i'm gonna show you the code
for
inference okay
so i'm taking the workspace
okay i'm telling it exactly what's the
workspace name what's the end point i
want to um target okay i'm passing it
the image and if
the image is this one okay
uh
no that's the emirates image sorry
the image is this one
and if i run this
it will tell me
that it's a singapore airlines plane
there you go
singapore airlines 99 if i comment this
and
give it um emirates airlines plane
just in case you don't trust that the
model actually does what it says it does
it's even more sure that the other file
which is this one
is a an emirates airlines uh plane okay
now
we are almost out of time so i'm not
going to do a demo for envelopes i'm
just going to talk a little bit about
amalops because what we saw um can be
used to build mlobs or devops for
machine learning or devops related
science or a little bit data ops okay
beyond the dogs mlops is a philosophy
okay it's not a tools it's like when
devops when you look at devops you look
at the people the process and the and
the products our technology that enables
continuous delivery of value to end
users that's the same thing we want to
achieve with the with machine learning
okay we want to go from iterating by
ourselves and close loops into full
circles where our code gets fully
managed fully deployed goes into
production
is monitored for again for data dorito
for any type of deviance during
production comes back and that flow
is not just
within the data science life cycle that
flow goes from data science in in into
into development teams goes into
production then comes back okay
i'm gonna give you uh i'm gonna move a
little bit faster i'm sorry so i'm gonna
tell you a little bit obviously you've
probably seen this before we are
connecting the
um
the right most two pieces which is
devops that we've heard of with the the
machine learning life cycle okay
what you saw today that helps you
achieve that you saw a little bit on the
azure machine learning piece which
covers the machine learning uh uh or
data science life cycle covers a little
bit of devops because i didn't show you
pipelines but you could have pipelines
inside azure machine learning you saw
the versioning you didn't see me
committing code to git but in the
background if you saw it on vs code they
were already the git button was enabled
and i was submitting the code to github
what's missing here is whenever i submit
it
whenever i did like a push on that on
all of that code that i use i was using
on uh
on vs code triggering a new build of
something that goes into production okay
so that automation piece that we can
achieve through um azure devops it's the
only miss that the only piece that was
missing today and that i didn't show you
okay
uh this is i'm gonna give this as
reference this is an ml ops
reference architecture that we've built
the links are at the bottom
if you can if you you have several
resources here
this is
the qr code for you to download the deck
with all the resources
my uh i don't do a lot of social media
unfortunately but if you just look at j
o a o b i
um i'm gonna put it it's in the
beginning of the session um
you can it's my email it's my pretty
much everything
whoops
and with that i will open up for any
questions